j'accueille maintenant au réel bonsoir
vous dire on m'avait dit que j'étais
jolie mais on vient travailler
ouais on m'avait pas raconter
d'histoires c'est magnifique
il a dû pour luchini lui sur rigoureuse
et de sa cote est de justement de
l'envoi le couche
pardonnez moi j'étais persuadé dans mon
clichés théorème temps d'aller voir sur
m6 je croyais que vous étiez vous savez
une grande vedette du sport en plus et
d'un sport hyper noble donc là ça
devient très très très allants alors
rocade on comprend là vous avez du bol
parce que vous avez une technique
maîtrisée parce que c'est hyper dur il
paraît kane un mysticisme quand on fait
le plein
les fils encore des films en costumes on
nous apprend qu'à relief tout ça des
gens qui nous apprend on est incapable
on prend les épaisseurs on est incapable
mais quand on sait qu'on a en face de
nous une femme qui maîtrise saha qui est
éblouissante de beauté ont le libre
alors mes amis mesdames messieurs chers
amis c'est pas vraiment la paix il a
juste 2 millions de gens qui veulent
savoir qu'il en avait c'est donc le 3,9
en 1999 laura flessel est devenue
championne du monde des scream
je suis fasciné par un vol ah bon alors
vous êtes en plus favorite pas pour les
jeux olympiques de sydney tout à fait en
fait pour le moment c'est moi qui
détiens les les titres en fait de chants
dont deux championnes olympiques donc ce
sont des titres à défendre donc dans
d'immenses verra ce que ça va donner
ouais alors vous êtes vous aimez bien
faire de la télé vous avez bien passat
et vous avez dit je suis d'une nature
curieuse et à force d'être tout le temps
passive devant la télévision et à
regarder a critiqué des émissions j'ai
voulu voir le travail en amont
oui tout à fait donc voila c'était un
plateau les cameramans regarder les
cadreurs voilà j'aurais dit bonjour en
passant donc cédric arrêtez ça tout seul
alors vous êtes né à pointe à pitre à
pointe à pitre c'est en guadeloupe
non mais toi tu savais jeune amant
j'avais noté jacques martin
vous avez commencé la danse à 6 ans à
l'âge de 6 ans et un jour vous voyez
jean françois lamour à la télévision en
fait j'étais fasciné par les films de
cape et d'épée plus exactement ça a
commencé avec ivanhoe non plus leurs
enfants là dessus dit platon
mousquetaires le bossu donc su donc de
fil en aiguille un jour j'ai vu une
rétrospective de match de simple c'était
pour moi des scream moderne et le
lendemain je me trouvais dans un club et
c'est parti comme ça ça à faire 23 ans
comme toi quand tu as vu un film de cul
le lendemain c'est dans un club
maintenant il ya donc vous avez été
plusieurs fois championne de guadeloupe
on vous appelle la guêpe wee man de
parme jeudi à m
ma petite taille lorsque j'ai commencé
les scream c'est vrai que j'étais fille
filiforme
mais j'avais le déborder d'énergie c'est
que savoir c'est que à l'origine j'étais
un petit garçon manqué donc je mange
tout d'un coup est en fait la première
compétition je ne connaissais que de
coups et on m'a dit tant qu'il n'ya pas
al tu continues tu vas chercher la
touche et en fait c'était assez
folklorique parce que la fille elle
était plaquée sur le mur et moi je
continue à piquer
alors vous êtes d'où vous êtes venus
alors arrivé en france en choeur enfin
métropole pardon en quelle année
en 90 91 on sait qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'étais déjà détecté mais j'avais
pas aussi je me sentais pas suffisamment
prêtes pour quitter ma famille quitter
le département le soleil et venir ici
donc j'ai dit que en fait je viendrai
après le bac donc à 18 ans avec le bac
il fallait qu'on ait une décision
parties à rester mais quand c'est arrivé
ici vous dites j'ai été laissé en marge
c'est une question de niveau mais
c'était ma couleur je faisais tâche vous
avez souffert on arrive à en france de
l'escrim c'est vrai que c'est une
certaine éthique scène une certaine
notoriété c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de noirs dans ce lancement dans
ce sport donc c'est vrai que quand je
suis arrivé surtout je suis arrivé dans
une équipe où il y avait déjà des
piliers qui ne voulait pas bouger et moi
j'arrivais je vais j'avais envie de
prouver de me prouver que je n'avais pas
quitter mon appartement pour rien et
vous êtes très guadeloupe avons marre
vous dessinez la guadeloupe sur vos
chaussures et tout ça vous êtes près 1
quand même vous êtes depuis la
guadeloupe indépendante ou non si on
peut si ça se prépare
pourquoi pas mais pour le moment on
n'est pas prêt on n'a pas suffisamment
les reins solides pour faire ça alors
maintenant j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
pour nous tous ici vous êtes marié face
et le coup dur ça arrive comme ça
brutalement
non il ya un truc terrible c'est que
vous dites quand je me regarde dans un
miroir c'est lui que je vois emballante
denis oui il est derrière ce moment
enfin moi je voyais et là c'est à dire
que bon effectivement si le fait d'être
marié est enfin là quand même quand
est-ce qu'on l'aura se voit dans un
miroir c'est de ne pas tout le temps se
regardant un poster à la patron j'ai eu
la chance de trouver un homme
compréhensif parce que c'est vrai que le
stade sud datée le haut niveau est quand
même lourd à gérer puisque quasiment
partie lui les journalistes donc lui
aussi de par son métier n'est jamais là
mais qu'on arrive à non non on arrive à
se retrouver c'est vrai que en fait on
arrive d'horizons différents puisqu'il
est d'origine yougoslave et
et en fait c'est vrai que bon on a quand
même pas mal de temps comment on se
complète avec lui tout à fait bien alors
de toute façon il ya plus grave encore
que de nice et après sydney ma plus
belle médaille ce sera mon bébé je
l'aurais assez attendu oui ça sera notre
dame est salle r toujours pour conquérir
la terre entière sait refroidissant une
fille qui aime son jules à ce point là
et qu'il veut un bébé de lui et tout de
suite apprécié et très bien au contraire
avant sur ça refroidit une expérience
nécessaire ça vous refroidit pas vous
fabrice lorsqu'il vous c'est que vous
avez dit une chose magnifique c'est que
c'est fusionnel avec denis que j'avais
bien vous êtes là qu il ait vous-même
quoi oui c'est beau c'est prodigieux et
ça vous angoisse par moment parce que
c'est une perte de la frontière dans les
angoisses pas non pas du tout mais quand
vous êtes lui par moments je pense et
lui vous c'est lui qui gagnent des
médailles d'or trois tweets l'attention
des enfants c'est une émission énorme
problème alors repasser au problème
premier problème vous avez décidé de
quitter le racing club de france qui
vous avez accueilli lorsque vous êtes
arrivé de guadeloupe
parce qu'ils veulent plus payer de prime
aux athlètes de haut niveau
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il
ya une nouvelle politique et la
politique justement rogner le sport de
haut niveau
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
scream c'est un sport amateur et que à
cause de ça enfin grâce à ça ça nous
permet d'avoir un certain équilibre
on est obligé de travailler donc on
garde un pied dans la vie active mais ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que
ne peut pas travailler à 100% donc un
manque à gagner que le club nous donnait
et le problème qui s'est passé c'est que
un an des jeux à dix mois des jeux ils
ont ils ont carrément décidé de retirer
son égard moi je pense que c'est un
problème politique
et comme nous le sportif n'avoue pas le
temps de s'occuper de votre caméra l'a
dit mme buffet on me dit non mais dites
lui profitent les ans pendant tout le
monde est au courant
donc en fait on a on a quand même opté
pour rester au club
pendant toute la saison à bonal et nous
je ne vais pas vous inscrire à chantilly
où ben c'était la date butoir de
pour changer en fait c'était le 15
novembre à la raison pour laquelle on
n'était pas plus qu'un pied les armes et
ça peut s'arranger
ben là on a trouvé un club accueillant
qui quoi au sport de haut niveau et qui
qui justement nous aider donc là on à
chantilly c'est incroyable alors on va
c'est le club de quoi de chantilly de
chantilly ce que je viens de faire bien
donc je dis ça pour les gens qui me
disent quel club en régie alors on va
regarder quelques quelques mais
catherine il faut on va regarder
quelques photos de vous formidable vous
allez m'expliquer ce que si ces photos
des regards et comme vous êtes belle
alors c'est après les jours en 96 jeunes
à nancy les vêtements de jean paul
gaultier bons caf est la suivante s'il
vous plaît monsieur kalfon voilà
toujours encore c'était
la collection avec l'écho les massaï
donc c'est vrai que je me prêtait à ces
photos et c'est vrai que c'était
magnifique
vous êtes très jolie encore une ola oui
cela est très bien c'est mal girafe de
l'est de la voilà avec le blé ski
moderne bien
alors maintenant je veux faire comme
c'est la première fois qu'on se voie je
vous faire une interview première fois
on ne bouge pas rien elle a bougé
voulait bouger là on recommence en rade
et attention je vais vous faire une
interview première fois
[Musique]
peut pas s'empêcher de vous est
craquante approche m'ont inscrit à vous
est tough fera quand bien premier
souvenir
bonjour j'ai rencontré jean françois
lamour guadeloupe
il est venu en plus en guadeloupe après
la télé vous a vu à la télé il est venu
vraiment moi aussi j'ai rencontré
l'amour c'est un jour il m'a signé le
premier autographe
ouais ça c'est grand souvenir c'est vrai
a décidé de votre vie premier péché dit
la vérité ici on dit la vérité c'est pas
comme d'habitude à la télé ici on dit la
vérité
j'avais plutôt les bonbons de mon frère
et j'avais juré que c'était pas moi non
je m'attendais à un prix beaucoup plus
hard
ces premiers essais le premier bon
deuxième à la première idole jean
françois lamour ont fait dire oui
c'était pas d'un mot non c'était carl
lewis à carl lewis premier amour mauvais
souvenirs à vent mauvais souvenir non
c'est un escrimeur à c'était un
escrimeur et j'en ris encore dans les
frimas
normalement tu devrais dire il tirait
mal c'est vrai ce que tu fous merde moi
bon premier flirt
il tirait mal non plus le même ouais
premier rhum premier amour premiers
flirts premier rhum c'est le même
escrimeurs zéro pointé c'est ça comment
il s'appelait à
moi c'est de ma faute votre première
cuite
j'attends toujours jean heureusement
peur du lendemain dont je ramène plutôt
que j'ai un bon 1er juin pas encore vous
avez tout à découvrir attendait mais se
formèrent décalage petit en twittant oui
premier dopage et j'envisage pas ah bon
vous droguez pas vous non pour le moment
je travaille sur mon bras comme un poète
champion du monde sans vous dopez mons
entraînant et en croyant en étant
entouré par une bonne
par de bonnes personnes rien que ça
c'est beau surtout que je suis passionné
donc oui ça sape l'audi sa championne
voici laura flessel
[Musique]
il a tort
tél
l'ofs les selles double championne
olympique des scream est votre dernière
visite ici laura flessel c'était en
novembre 1999 et nous avions parlé du
dopage c'était prémonitoire et
j'envisage pas ah bon vous droguez pas à
vous non pour le moment je savais
comment fonctionnera comme on peut être
champion du monde sans vous dopez mons
entraînant et en croyant
en étant entouré par une bonne
dans de bonnes personnes ça c'est beau
surtout à celle que je suis passionné
donc ouais ça s'applaudit sa championne
mais monde sans dopage et voilà voilà
mais laura flessel avant que tu ailleurs
des lois dans la conversation
sache que tout ça est arbitré et lorsque
tu toucheras alors laura flessel le
voyant rouge ça viendra comme il est
d'usagé en escrime vas-y c'est normal
vous ne veut doper pas mais en mai 2002
lors de la coupe du monde de malaga vous
terminé deuxième et donc vous subissez
laura flessel un contrôle anti dopage
tout à fait classique
hélas est presque trois mois plus tard
donc en août 2002 vous apprenez pas par
la fédération d'ailleurs mais par le
journal l'équipe que votre contrôle
étaient positifs que s'est il passé
tout bêtement le kiné de l'équipe de
france ils ont bien remis une mallette
attendait ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
assez de médecins à la fédération et que
certaines fois vous êtes accompagné par
les kinés par de simples ine et donc
voilà c'est ce qui n'est le vôtre
s'appelle david soulié sa pharmacie
n'avait plus en stock de de pastilles de
sel et de sucre classique et la
pharmacie a remplacé par des comprimés
de coramine glucose sans connaître le
fait qu'elle interprète ce mois tant
appris on n'a pas le droit
tu peux aller pisser là le gars lui a
remis en fait en lui disant puisque le
kiné et lui a certifié qu'il partait
avec une équipe de france donc il
fallait absolument qu'il fasse très
attention et ce fameux pharmaciens en
fait lui a donné de la kora ni glucose
en disant il n'y a pas de problème voilà
sauf que dans l'accord 1min cause il ya
du nice et asni ii sans déconner alors
qu'il a tout de suite fait attention
que justement la commune de glucose
n'altère pas en altère en rien la
performance donc ce n'est pas du dopage
alors on peut dire donc c'est un petit
peu comme richard virenque laura flessel
c'était un petit peu drogués à l'insu de
votre plein gré il nous a même façon en
faisant confiance à aux staffs médicaux
staff fédéral
mais dans ces cas là il ya aucun
problème j'ai un email pour dire qu'il a
peut être un faux contact dans le
collier puis ça fait deux fois qu'elle
est touché et ça ça ne l'est pas alors
on respectives de mer donc laura en
septembre 2002 le tribunal disciplinaire
à lausanne vous condamnent quand même à
trois mois de suspension c'est qu'en
faire oui mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que étant donné qu'on a on a bien
prouvé qu'il n'y avait aucune
amélioration de performance on s'est
vite rendu compte que c'est en fait
c'était juste une guéguerre entre deux
je dirais de fédération puisque ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la france n'a
jamais été un peu je dirais jamais le
mouton de panurge de la fédération
internationale et donc à travers cette
histoire ils ont réglé leur compte la
seule chose que le la balle c'était moi
avec pas le droit de 6,6 on s'entraîne
moi je me lève je n'ai jamais et son
contrôle judiciaire à ckoi résidence
surveillée non non absolument mais ça va
quand même très bien et damien escrime
bah oui
bon c'est du beau gosse vicieux comme ça
dit bien ce qu'il a une touche j'aurais
tendance à sortir mal apparemment non le
problème pourrait tout à fait clair
c'est que cette histoire vous a fait
perdre leur à flesselles vos sponsors
parce qu'il y avait dans votre contrat
il y avait une clause anti dopage qui
disait si laura flessel et contrôlé
positif le contrat du sponsor s'annulent
automatiquement
vous avez perdu vos sponsors et et vous
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de mal à
faire face à vos engagements financiers
il ya neuf mois ma fédération a crié
haut et fort qu'ils avaient fait une
erreur et qu'ils allaient régler cette
situation neuf mois après on est encore
à la case départ et personnes personne
ne bouge peut-être que ce soit va
retrouver un sponsor c'est un
laboratoire pharmaceutique de ses côtes
non je dirais que c'est moins que neuf
mois après ben on a on a envie de taper
un peu le point sur la table c'est à
dire que étant donné que moi j'ai été
j'ai subi à la période aujourd'hui il ya
un préjudice financier et moral juste un
petit exemple il ya je travaille avec
des enfants et il ya deux trois jours il
ya un enfant qui me dit mais vous savez
en fait il s'est pas rendu compte que
c'était moi donc on a parlé on a tiré
ensemble et puis finalement ça c'est
plus que trois mois et à la fin de la
séance j'ai ouï mais il ya laura flessel
qui devait passer 1 et elle n'est pas
venue en chine oui et donc je me suis
rendu compte qu'il ne savait pas que
c'était moi j'écoute j'écoute me dit oui
c'est c'la noir qui fait d'eux les
scream qui est championne olympique et
qui a eu qui restait trois mois en
prison d'un collyre ou alors la donne
en fait j'ai dû à ça tous les petits en
disant écoutez vous savez le 8 9 et 10
mois et dix ans et j'en ai dit écoutez
fallait absolument fait régler la
situation et dire trois mois ferme c'est
une sanction on va pas en prison
et à chaque fois depuis neuf mois je
suis obligé de faire les écoles mais là
elle n'a pas la parole va se diffuser
dans la france entière
peut-être qu'elle je n'ai plus à le
redire alors voilà donc la fédération
monsieur abric
le patron de la fédération promet de
vous aider laura flessel malheureusement
ça va pas très vite il ne fait pas
vraiment le ton monte et il a regretté
quand même parce que effectivement y la
gamme regretté sur la place publique que
vous dépensiez sans compter il vous a
accusé de faire de la cavalerie
on va replacer les choses dans leur
contexte sachant que l'escrimé est un
sport amateur que je suis obligé de
travailler
donc forcément il fallait que je trouve
quelque part une compensation d'où
l'idée du rôle de l'état l'âge n'ont
voulu
d'avoir des sponsors donc j'y arrivais à
avoir des sponsors sur une compagnie
d'assurance que je ne cite pas donc à ce
jour j'ai perdu mes sponsors le je veux
juste à mon dieu c'est tout mon argent
mes sponsors sont partis il ya eu
préjudice qu'ils étaient chiffrées ouais
ça s'arrête là
laura flessel vous avait assigné la
fédération un peu à contrecoeur mais
hier quand même 9 - calysto attendait ça
j'attaque désolé mais enfin à un an des
jeux olympiques d'athènes ça ou flinguer
le moral d'être en conflit que votre
fédération ça va pas nous faire gagner
c'est encore non si tout ça arrange bien
oui oui dites moi c'est pas denis qui
vous pousse un peu à faire tout ça non
non pas du tout pas du tout non munis de
nice a donné entre cet amour guy ya des
il ya dépend de votre vie qui met entre
eux je n'ai pas demandé mon avis c'est
la dernière fois que laura est venue
elle m'a dit qu'ils allaient mieux
qu'une médaille olympique
ça serait d'avoir un bébé et depuis le
bébé est né se portent bien
voilà tu as fait ce soir c'est denis qui
garde le bébé de celle elle est tout
seul bien
nora regarder votre caméra et dit un mot
à pierre abric parce que peut-être que
ce soir non peut-être qu'on peut régler
le problème ce soir bien sûr aller en
justice
vega pierre a dit jeudi que j'espère
vraiment que kill kill qui s'est rendu
compte que ça fait neuf mois et que ben
c'est pas avec ce que lui nous donne qu
on convient bien donc
donc voila quoi jeter ses
responsabilités et puis voilà
cette jeune femme voilà il est évident
qu'elle est sincère
on sait que tout en elle dit qu'elle a
raison voilà à l'ailière fais pas ton
couillon flux la paix pierre piroi fait
lui de l'étude
[Musique]